hey guys Dennis here and I want you know
that my teaser trailer for my science
fiction webseries nuclear salvation is
going to be premiering at the geeky
awards on sunday august 18 so if you're
watching this when i've uploaded this
video on saturday that means it's going
to be tomorrow night and if you're
watching on sunday that means it's going
to be on later tonight so how can you
watch the geeky awards and see the
nuclear salvation teaser trailer well
that's easy all you have to do is click
on the link i'm going to put in the
description below the whole ward show is
going to be streamed live on ustream and
it starts at five-thirty p.m. pacific
standard time that's the red carpet
that's eight thirty eastern standard
time the actual show itself starts at
seven-thirty p.m. pacific time standard
time and ten thirty eastern standard
time so what are the geeky awards their
awards show that are focusing on geek
centered creators artists filmmakers
Stanley is going to be there is going to
be presented with a lifetime achievement
award there's also going to be cool
presenters like Seth Green Grant Imahara
and Richard Hatch which you know from
the original Battlestar Galactica and
Alison Haislip is going to be hosting so
if you want to check out the trailer
make sure you watch the show and let me
know what you think I know it's going to
play at least once i'm not sure if
they're playing multiple times but it's
going to be during the commercial breaks
i'm actually going to be at the show
live it's actually a few blocks away
from my place it's gonna be a great time
and i'll talk to you guys soon